okay so we are very much in prep mode
oh hi welcome to this video so we were
very much in prep mode because we're
doing our very first nofilter show
tonight in London and no spoilers okay
and so I don't have a ton of time and I
just shot a something this morning for a
secret project I know you all [ __ ]
hate me saying that now but when it
comes out I think he'll be like okay yes
this is pleasing to us you know variety
of ways but wait for that
mamrie just went downstairs so I don't a
lot of time to film a video but I want
to try and prank fame where she's going
to come back upstairs and she's with the
prince on yourself I'm gonna see if I
can prank
see how we wait to see when she gets
back you owe me my mom is sick too great
last night
my legs were sweating like you need the
thigh sweat in between your legs when
you break your legs look up each other
let me sleep on your side and just like
cactuses
why does this happen in this Erica so oh
damn it
oh man you've been pranked
Shammi yeah you got pranked so hard
dammit dammit I waited in that closet
for like 20 seconds god damn it I'm
gonna prank Hanna when she gets here
okay perfect yeah
yes you can hi we're okay now we're
gonna be here a few more hour oh um yeah
towels will be great okay
it is three o'clock right now that's
when Hanna is supposed to be here so
let's get ready
please be on time Hanna okay light
reading
oh no it's in patan okay oh hi hang in
there yes yes it's a date
very minimalist this is just a wrinkle
in time
ooh excuse me hey ton
no wonder what sediment in heaven with
me is like I'm gonna take a pause gotta
go get we just got I'm not gonna be able
to play like you're not here because I
would say it when I go get her
oh why are we come out like we're
Graceland yeah okay great okay now's the
time that was the time yeah dude off in
a friend with your [ __ ] idiots
yeah should talk to somebody named Joe
and Joe is gonna make sure that they
don't then today there's an exception
they don't stop with something right
girl okay I don't know she was here
yeah gotcha Sun God is so cool thank you
I got so good we got just sell direct
you feel like it you feel like a stupid
idiot
you thought I feel like doing some
mundane activity on my computer with my
idiot yeah it is so good yeah finally
over after all these years I know but
you're super backless like I can get
your face
I got you though okay now I need to
rehearse
I don't know keep expecting for me to be
sitting casually in a corner possible
doing work or maybe using the restroom
doing some other mundane activity but
instead I'm in the glass and I don't
tell you